this podcast and every other podcast
that I make is brought to you by patreon
did you use LimeWire
I was like that's maybe not a great kind
of question to ask someone who works in
music no I mean I actually
um I never LimeWire was kind of after my
time but Napster like OG Napster yeah
that was there was a lot of I was big
into I was a soundtrack collector and I
really wanted the physical CDs so I had
very little use for Netflix Netflix for
Napster but the big exception was there
were a lot of things that were like
otherwise not available it wasn't that
they were like unreleased that somehow
some person would find and digitize and
you'd be like oh here's you know here's
a score to a movie that that it never
got a soundtrack album but someone
somehow got a hold of the tapes
digitized them and they've made their
way onto the internet and so I did use
it quite a lot for downloading mp3s and
things that were that were literally not
available I feel like that's okay but I
also I'm like well I'm gonna come to my
house now you know who knows most of
that [__] was subsequently made
available and because it went through
official channels it was usually in
better quality so I ended up buying 99
of of that stuff in the long run I was
never a fan of the kind of
um uh like uh you know bands uh suing uh
their fans or whatever who who had that
stuff like it was a very wild west
uh window and you could tell that it was
you could tell that it was like this is
a new technology that nobody that's what
I feel like the biggest risk of viruses
was like as a young girl using LimeWire
I was not so much at risk but I feel
like every boy that was in my class was
because of the amount of like huge boobs
that would just come up for any search
in LimeWire it was all pawn titles and
I'm pretty sure those were all the
viruses but I was never really
interested in it but I'm pretty sure
that's how everybody got done and now
yeah like I don't really think about my
antivirus very much
well that's the thing I mean window like
I I tend to never this is where I'd be
curious if if our comments yield
correction to me on this but my
impression was that basically the last
few major updates to Windows with the
Windows Defender is Far and Away
like industry standard in terms of that
like all your all your default McAfee
and blah blah blah are not really better
than what Windows does naturally I'm
pronounced McAfee
that's how I thought it was pronounced
is it I always heard it as McAfee but I
never said documentary about him on
Netflix
really yeah the guy who made it if you
watch it it crashes your computer and I
don't know what it is exactly but I I
think I remember it being like like
something crazy like he killed a guy
like something nuts I didn't I was like
I'm just about to say evidence that
we've run out of subjects for
documentaries but then you immediately
McAfee killed the guy hang on let me
check if that's right with a virus
Netflix document programs their computer
like in a like in a um
um some kind of like Mission Impossible
movie style thing where like made the
computer overheat and set the house on
fire hell yeah the the series is called
Running With the Devil and it exposes
millionaire John McAfee's escape from
the law and I'm pretty sure there was an
episode that was something about him
[__] killing a guy
well he's on the run from the law for
something yup and not for making
antivirus software I assume the leading
question is did John McAfee kill his
neighbor
wow murdered his Belizean neighbor as an
act of Revenge for poisoning his dogs
wow there you go it's top what a drama
what a what a dramatic cul-de-sac it's
the only way you got to make a
documentary um speaking of dramatic
cul-de-sacs the Grammys
laughs excellent Segway thank you
um you went and you looked awesome
yeah I I'm not gonna lie I was one of
those where I
as evidenced by my uniform of my red
stoic sweatshirt uh clearly I put a lot
of thought and expressive weight into my
dress code
um but and the last time I went to the
Grammys I I just wore like this it was
actually really cool looking but it was
just basically solid black everything
like shirt I think I've seen perfect tie
yeah it was one of those normally I do a
little bit of color mix and match but
this one was just I don't know look cool
but um
but dating a cosplayer yeah changes the
formula it was so good and so yeah she
was like
I'd like to buy a like we literally went
to a thrift store to buy a Blazer that
was convincing and not looked nice but
was cheap enough that she could paint
all over it and basically have her way
with it and it wouldn't yeah like the
one-off nature of it was gonna be okay
and of course she did an amazing job and
then made yeah this little like tie clip
brooch of a little face hugger
um and uh uh then with her own she had
this crazy like
xenomorph tail thing and the little egg
as well
so those no they they were actually hand
attached they look like metal but
they're actually silver painted pieces
of cardboard because cosplayer yeah and
just like whatever gets the look because
it really did look even up close it
looked like little pieces of cut sheet
metal or something but she has one of
those she has one of those like uh laser
printer laser cutters where you can
upload a kind of schematic and it will
do a laser oh yeah yeah on on the
whatever material on paper or what and
it could it can cut on cardboard so she
took it literally from like an Amazon
box or something
and and made a million of these little
v-shaped dude uh things on the template
do you mind if I show a picture
no not at all yeah
because I don't want to pull it up
that's the best I can do it's very
blurry but yeah it's perfect Angela is
so [__] cool Austin she's just so
cool and when I saw this I was like dude
because you were nominated for alien
right that's why yeah exactly it was for
for my for aliens fire team
um it's so cool you guys look awesome
like that's such a good idea and yeah
definitely a benefit of dating a
cosplayer is that you like I I imagine
it was her idea um but she had messages
oh yeah because I have a pretty terrible
fashion sense and I'm trying to get
better and she was like next time you
have something let me know and I was
like I could just invite Angelo over and
be like here's my wardrobe what do I
wear at the dice Awards like you'd
probably be way cooler than anything I
could come up with she no it's a real I
mean she became in the like Latin
American ecosystem sort of Central and
South America World of Cosplay she
became like one of the top I don't know
five six of like they she went to every
Comic-Con basically in the Western
Hemisphere other than in the U.S as a
cosplay judge yeah she did a journey
cosplay and we were we were friends for
I don't know a year year and a half or
something like that before we started
dating but we initially met literally
from Twitter when somebody
tagged me I think Sony actually I think
the Santa Monica Twitter account like
retweeted her journey cosplay because it
was the best I'd ever seen by a mile
like and she shot it in Egypt on the
sand dunes like so it was oh yeah yeah
she was there judging a cosplay thing at
like a Cairo Comic-Con they had brought
her out and I think two nights before
the trip she went oh man because she was
originally playing this was right after
Force awakens came out so she was
originally going to do this Rey cosplay
out in the desert photo shoot as part of
the festival thing and then literally 72
hours or something before the flight
went oh man I should do a journey one
while I'm out there and
um and just kind of made it within the
last few like the last day and change
before her flight and did the shots and
and you know it was like all these
websites kind of shared it around and on
Reddit and stuff of like holy hell look
at these photos and it made its way to
me and we just became friends and that's
when I discovered she was a painter and
started commissioning paintings and and
and then you know everything went from
there but
um but yeah so [__] the cosplay thing is
like her hobby but for this it was like
okay you know what I know I tend to
it's not that I'm conservative in my
dress it's just that I'm low maintenance
I don't like to put a lot of energy yeah
I'm like it's lazy like I right now I'm
wearing this giant oversized PlayStation
sweater and some tights which is because
I knew that I had boxing training today
so I was like let me just put on the
thing I box in and just wear that all
day which is like very lazy most people
get changed out of their workout clothes
I probably smell but I'm like I'm at
home
who cares it's lazy yep no for sure
maybe honestly if you smell horrible uh
the dog likes it the little bitty Grant
yes said the dog is gonna approve
exactly um who cares
um but like but yes I just don't respect
the hell out of fashion though I think
like when people do do it it's not a
thing that I'm like why would you waste
your time doing that I'm like it's
really cool I just don't have it in me
to like I'm trying to to care and I had
mentioned it to Angela and she was like
completely agree yeah hit me up and I
was like dude you're so [__] cool
it's one of those things that I want to
make space in my mind for it's like I
want to want to uh I totally that's
exactly what it is for me is make space
in my mind that's what it is like I feel
the same way about makeup I think makeup
is very cool and very fun and when I do
it I enjoy it however I don't have the
space in my mind for it it's that I'm
like I can't prioritize doing this
especially on a daily basis when there
are so many other things I already have
to think about and it's not that I don't
like it or like think it's awesome when
people like do really cool stuff with
makeup especially cosplayers they can do
crazy cool stuff it's just a different
kind of art they don't have the space in
my mind
to to do it like me it's it's pretty
it's pretty common that composers like
I'm very much the norm I think amongst
My Tribe but there are a couple of
composers that routinely just like
there's a guy Dan Pemberton who it's not
that he's a like fashionista type but he
always dresses strikingly like bright
he'll wear like a track suit that's
bright orange or something
um and it's just it's it's it's like
it's very him it's very predictably him
and the other one is Ludwig gorenson who
did the Black Panther movies and the
Mandalorian
um he if you just Google image him he's
always dressed as if he was on his way
to a to a runway show or something I
mean he's just he's one of those people
that has made clothing
and music seemingly equal
places of personal expression and it's
one of those where I'm like man
that's I I do think it's awesome
oh yeah no for sure all right no I tried
to tell me once it was like he goes the
day that you call me to say all right
take me shopping we'll be the happiest
day it has yet to happen I've met Danny
Elfman a couple of times over the last
year because he scored a movie that
Rahul is in and he always has a really
distinct and interesting fashion sense
always a lot of color I don't think I've
ever seen him in a suit he's always
wearing something that was like so
Danny Elfman in a way that I'm like do
you have to is it part of it is that you
have to know yourself really well to
have a good fashion sense like how
especially when we're talking about like
how artists like people at the Grammys
um compose this particularly one that's
such like a it's a less
like uh
uh market like your your image is not
quite as marketed as it is for
other kinds of every other musician yeah
pretty much so like for I mean there are
people specifically to like get really
into how they look I think it's just
super interesting yeah I mean if you
think about like Hans Zimmer is right up
there alongside John Williams as among
the single most well-known by names
but most people would pass them on the
street and have the have the famous clue
a couple of people have distinctive
looks like Mark mother's bar very
famously has a distinctive look
Danny just kind of he like Danny Elfin
somehow manages to look exactly like who
you think the composer of like
Beetlejuice and Nightmare Before
Christmas should look but he's also so
so sweet he's so oh yeah so nice because
um it's the movie roles in it's called
next exit
well his daughter was the director so
that that adds to some of them exactly
so when Daddy comes up to us
to Rahul he's always like thank you so
much for what you did for my daughter
and he's done it almost every time we've
seen him he's so sweet and nice and like
it was also an interesting one where
that movie
he wasn't going to do it unless he
really liked the movie like he was like
I'm not gonna do this just on the Merit
of I I'm hoping I'm recounting this
correctly but I'm not going to do that
just on the Merit of this being my
daughter this has to be a movie that
like I think that I Vibe with that works
for me
um and so he did and the score is
beautiful and very very different from
anything he's done because a very
different movie to anything he's done
but he's just like
one of those people where you're you're
right that he looks exactly the way that
you would expect the Beetlejuice
composer to look but at the same time
he's a really sincere sweet person like
there are some people like that you just
like
man you are just you and that's [__]
awesome it's just really cool
he is if you watch on the Netflix uh on
the Siri there's a Netflix series called
um
um there's a few there's there's the
movies that made us and I'm pretty sure
there's an episode about nightmare
Before Christmas I've seen the games
that made us and the toys that made us
yeah there's a movies one as well but
there's for sure there's a
prop culture there's a show called prop
culture which is also I think I've
talked about on here that's about it's
all it's on Disney plus because it's all
Disney films but there's definitely a
nightmare before Christmas and they they
interviewed Danny a lot for it because
obviously it being a musical you know he
was working on it well before they'd
even begun animation and stuff and and
so he was you know very integrated in
fact I'm pretty sure he was dating the
the screenwriter like that's kind of how
it all started to come about I can't
remember the particulars but
um but yeah it's one of those that you
expect a kind of psychotic madman uh and
he kind of looks the part and I've been
to his studio and his Studio very much
looks the part it's full of like pumpkin
skeletons and oh yeah you know it's like
it's it's exactly what you would expect
in elephant Studio to look like so then
what's your equivalent of that what's
your studio if this is mine which is
this is I mean you're looking at it yeah
so like it's it's pretty messy but you
have a lot of stuff you've got
music like you've got that it's not as
messy as it could be uh but it is it's
way Messier yeah you're all right but
it's not like I'm saying you're not like
a the type of composer who's like got
folders everything's structured and
perfectly clean and organized you're not
that in the computer yes in real life
outside I'm very anal with my file
organization because these folders get
so elaborate yeah but um
but yeah I my whole shtick with this
space is that I don't have posters on
the wall of things I've worked on
um uh and I don't keep I don't I don't
keep like uh trophies or or uh things
like like you know uh
uh
mementos basically of any form of past
Pro they're all they're all through this
door
um because this needs to be a neutral
space that is about looking ahead and
not not resting on one's Laurels
interesting and um I if I didn't have
the space for them in another room
they'd be in a closet boxed up because
to me I always am paranoid I just have
seen so many composers who kind of like
started strong and then seemingly began
to kind of believe their own [__] and
then their music just kind of gradually
gets more and more bland and I'm like I
think the only way that happens is if
there are effectively each time going
you know
pretty good at this I'm thinking and and
like that belief is not what led them to
create the initial good thing yeah or
like obviously I have tons of God of War
stuff here I do have a trophy shelf that
I love that is off camera is up the top
like I prefer that people don't see that
all the time uh but I wonder if that's a
thing where
you think about the thing that you're
defined for and feel like you have to
recreate that like maybe it's not all
ego it's like if you have you know if
you have God of War posters everywhere
in your bear McCreery who clearly did
not do this to be clear but as a
terrible example maybe you think this is
the thing everybody knows me for and you
see it and you get the reminder of it
all the time and you feel like that you
have to like put yourself in that box
you have to not stray away from that one
thing you've made it too much of your
identity potentially
I think for yeah that could be
um uh I could also see that being the
exact opposite where you're like I'm so
desperately trying to get away from the
thing that like like it happens all the
time that somebody
like for composers at least it happens
all the time that you'll score like
a hit comedy okay so using bear as an
example his mentor was one of these
legendary composers named Elmer
Bernstein Elmer scored
um uh like he did the original
Ghostbusters he did a ton of comedies in
the 70s and 80s Animal House
um and uh Ghostbusters and
um stripes and uh there's there's
there's a zillion of them and then he
also did a lot of like dramas
um uh he won an Oscar for Thoroughly
Modern Millie he did and then he also
did a ton of westerns like the most
iconic one of the most iconic scores of
all time the Magnificent Seven
um and he also did a bunch of like
biblical epics like the Ten Commandments
he did the original To Kill a
Mockingbird uh you know one of these
legendary careers and
um he Elmer always talked about how he
would score he'd he would do like a
magnificent seven and it would be such a
hit that for 10 years he'd do nothing
but westerns and he would just be like
longing to do something other than a
western by the end but then he would do
an animal house and have 10 years of
nothing but comedies he you know like
airplane was another great comedy score
of his
um and then you know or like to Kill a
Mockingbird and nothing but non-stop
dramas and so that's like a classic the
whole pigeonholing idea is a classic
phenomenon now I have heard a composer a
friend of mine a guy named Tyler Bates
who did like the Guardians of the Galaxy
and and the John Wick movies
um he's advocates in favor of that
because he's basically like whatever it
like to your point if that's your thing
you like it's good to have a thing
especially if it's a thing that is like
you know mainstream like if you're a
horror person they're never going to
stop making horror movies be the person
that they just immediately think of when
they think of horror movies
yourself on the like slightly lower
level like not to
discount anyone but when you're not like
a super famous composer it's probably
easier to Market yourself as being the
go-to for a particular genre I would
think yeah oh and there's plenty of
examples of this like there are so many
composers that you're like you you go
I've never heard like say you watched
some random film ago I never heard of
this person you look it up and you see
on their IMDb 50 other movies similar to
the one that you just watched yeah
you're like Ah that's how that goes and
it happens in TV as well it kind of
happens in games but I think most
composers aspire to the opposite I
certainly do you know with my all-time
hero being Jerry Goldsmith his whole
schnick was just like your portfolio is
very diverse you've worked on a ton of
different stuff
and that was always the goal the goal
was always you know like if I did an
action thing I'd want to follow it up
with you know
like like
this and yeah yeah like the like the
like the the thing that came after
Journey was Monaco followed shortly by
Leisure Suit Larry yeah you know it was
like as about unjourney as you can get I
mean I don't deny that my heart
I really really love working on those
like I remember once when you saw the
initial reveal of heart machines solar
Ash and you said something like that
seems like a game Austin would score I I
do like that there like I do like those
kinds of games like I loved you know
working on abzu and pathless and there's
a new one coming out soon that's kind of
I would say in that sort of world that's
called strayed lights
um not to be confused with stray Gods
the musical it was not my intention to
have or stray yes this is not that was
not well choreographed by the Puppet
Masters of the Universe but
um can't always be but like there are
some there are some that I I'm like yeah
I I do have a soft spot for working on
things like that but I also we said this
to you before and I still think it
stands that you have a um which I I feel
like Austin is like
such a testament to you is that there's
a quality seal which is if I know that
you have composed something I it speaks
to me of the entire game if I if I like
this is before I even knew you right if
you had composed something I assume or
no it is going to be a good game and
that I don't think applies to any other
composer that I know in video games at
least where I feel like that's because
that's the direction that you come from
and that you uh you like working with
teams in a certain way your approach is
how do we collaborate as a team thus you
tend to have a lot of faith in the
projects you work on at least that's the
way I see it I I for sure think if
Austin has scored a game oh that's very
it is a indication that the game is of
good quality but maybe that's
you may be that's very kind and very
generous and and you know one would hope
that's true there's always those cases
where you work on a thing
where you know at the onset you know
everyone's looking at concept art and
the design documents and it looks like
this is going to be just the best thing
ever and then by the time you've gone
through all the hurdles and the whips
and Scorn of shipping it you're like
we've kind of drifted off course perhaps
I mean totally yeah you know I've yeah
but you know I don't know I've been very
lucky I mean I I've never had to like I
always loved my friend Jack wall the guy
he worked on the Mass Effect uh
franchise and he's done most all of the
Black Ops
branch of the Call of Duty games
um and a bunch of others wonderful guys
been in games for a long time he
a story of his that I love is like my
quintessential story I give to Young
composers when they're like messaging
going I'm gonna go to GDC for the first
time ever what should I do
my number one advice is basically just
taken from Jack which was
uh jack work in the mid 90s Jack worked
on a like you know early CD-ROM one of
these things that I think would probably
just like come if you bought a PC and it
just like came with a little bundle of
discs for things and there was one of
these games I could be wrong about the
exact nature but one of these games it
was it was called like Barbie island
adventure or something and it was
basically a kids game and Jack worked on
this you know early in his career gave
it his all had a great friendly Dynamic
with the audio director that audio
director then
spent the next 15 years or whatever
moving I'm assuming amongst a bunch of
sound design jobs and not in a position
to hire a composer but literally 15
years later on call on Black Ops 2 was
now back in a role where he was in a
hiring position and off of the memory of
working with Jack on Barbie island
adventure 15 years later just cold
called him and just sighed on scene said
would you like to score Call of Duty
Black Ops and Jack's done all of them
since then and done tremendous work I
mean really all especially I love the
all the big band jazz that he's done for
the zombie mode stuff in those is so
awesome and so
um I always use that as like when you
actually connect with someone the game
kinda doesn't matter uh like if you're
if you're if this is a career investment
uh it's all about the people at the end
the more that because the product is a
function of so many variables that are
out of any one person's control even the
publisher or the game director or
anybody even highly influential people
on a project can't force a thing to be
great everyone tries their best and
sometimes reality says otherwise it's
hot or it's it's hard or sometimes it's
a game that's you know it's aspiring to
a very simple maybe simplest the wrong
way to describe it like I don't think
Barbie island adventure or whatever it
was was aspiring to be game of the year
I think it had a very specific Mission
and presumably or hopefully it achieved
whatever it was after and but I always
think it's very noteworthy that Jack
made an impression that a decade and a
half plus later with and they weren't
like hanging out in that intervening
period I think that's like they were
best friends
yeah go for it and
yeah that's because you're and I've been
very lucky that I haven't had many of
those Barbie Island Adventure Time like
my first commercial release was flow
yeah like that's pretty good completely
lucky
yeah no that does anything wrong with
that like because I have friends who've
worked in
um
like a friend who wrote on Kotor oh
apparently my internet connection is
unstable that's fun
um a friend who wrote on you froze for a
split second for me but yeah
um that
now is in Mobile
and I know this has happened to a bunch
of video game writers that I've known
people who've worked on games that are
considered to be incredible in terms of
writing that now work in the mobile
space doing what again potentially the
wrong word but to write things that are
much more simple less involved and less
stressful as they get older uh I respect
it it's like it can be very very hard to
spend years writing a grueling harrowing
story with branching parts of something
like Koto
um and then you go to mobile where you
have to write
you know you still want to do something
good but all the Kotor work still leads
into the mobile work it's it's still
Game Dev it's still challenging but like
it's just a different variation of that
I don't think those things are any less
valid I don't think they are like any
less writing it's just a different kind
of writing and it's about how much of
your own time you want to keep to
yourself because it's a thing that will
happen to me I imagine for as long as I
work at Santa Monica Studios I'm always
thinking about what I'm working on that
I don't I go to bed at night and I'm
thinking about work at all times
seems nice that maybe in 20 years I'd
write in Candy Crush and I check out at
five
and I wake up the next day and I I do my
best writing but I get to just sleep
like that doesn't seem to be so bad it
it yeah I mean yeah it it
um
everybody has an evolving like yeah
continuous evolution of relationship and
every job you have is a resume for the
next job you get to like in a lot of
ways in the games industry where
everyone knows each other's so connected
um but to get slightly back on track
yeah how was how was the Grammys what
was your experience like the Grammys
were fun you know it was it was um
what why were you there I know but a lot
of people we already established a fire
team was nominated in their first ever
so they it's interesting they they
created this year a new category they
split the soundtrack category into two
one that's film and TV which uh Jermaine
Franco won for Encanto and then
um and then the video game specifically
it's called games and and interactive
other interactive media
um and there's technically four
soundtrack category the the Grammys is
broken into what they call Fields so
there's like a rock feel or like I can't
remember if they call it a rock but
there's for sure like a jazz field
there's a classical field
um and
um uh I'm trying to think of some of the
others off the top of my head but
there's I don't know maybe 10 of those
and then there's the actual uh
categories underneath that and they all
some of them have different like there's
probably I think 10 classical
uh categories in the in that field
because there's you know best orchestral
performance uh best solo performance
best large Ensemble best chamber
Ensemble best
uh Opera performance like you know Etc
and so
um
and actually as a funny side note
Beyonce
won uh she she became the most
grammy-winning person in all of grammy
history like one individual she now
holds the all-time record of across all
Fields all categories wow of of
um Grammy wins with I think 32 now
um and like something like 80
nominations
um but what's interesting the thing that
they didn't mention was that who she
dethroned was the Chicago Symphony
conductor George Schulte who was the
reigning champion and what's so funny is
because classical music
despite being relatively marginal in
terms of pop culture is extremely
prolific like there are there's like a
you could go find probably 50 recordings
or more of just like Beethoven's Ninth
Symphony yeah one piece will have a
million each one of which would be
eligible in its own entry every year so
all these classical music Heroes Leonard
Bernstein George Schulte if you look
through the history of the Grammys it's
actually very funny that yes of course
there's like Quincy Jones Paul McCartney
Adele there's people that you know
Michael Jackson that you would expect to
see in the like all time record holders
but it's solidly like 50
of those all-time most both nominations
and winless dominated by people in the
classical and John Williams who I think
is the fourth highest earning Grammy
winner of all time with I think he's won
like 25 or 24. do you think classical is
that because like I love classical music
always have you know like how in full so
you can choose a radio station I love
driving to classical music
um but
do you think classical is so prevalent
there because the I don't know if they
call it the academy for the Grammys like
they see it as more difficult or like is
it a pretentious thing is it that it's
like again they think it's harder like
what do you think is the the thing that
makes classical above jazz or whatever
else seem to dominate
oh I think it's I think it's actually
just that it I think that they dominate
I all I'm saying that they dominate in
is that there are a handful of people in
that field
who happened to be at the Grammys again
and again and again and I think it's
actually because there's a bunch of
categories and there is
um
uh uh like comparatively less
competition so like if you Ascent if you
become
one of the top conductors in the world
and you're making recordings all the
time you're all but guaranteed to be
Grammy nominated every year for whatever
your latest because there's only so many
people that are going to be up at bat
against you so it's like the pyramid the
top of the pyramid is a pretty small
place I guess I have very and there's a
bunch of different categories so there's
like many opportunities yeah under
classical there's at least 10 different
so you have very little understanding of
new classical to be honest like
everything I listen to is very very old
it's re-recordings of old songs but
those would all be eligible like if I
they're all eligible because yeah
because the Grammys is all about album
skus basically so if I release if I
personally go and do a piano you know
Moonlight Sonata piano record I could
submit that to the Grammys and viable
whether I would be good enough or
whatever but I could viably
hypothetically speaking be nominated for
a brand new recording of a Beethoven so
then how many
the amount of times
wouldn't it be tons
oh yeah I would imagine like I bet you
he beats Beyonce
do you think he knew that one day we'd
be sitting here over the Internet
talking about how many Grammys he's won
I I wish somebody this this it's funny
because I just I just thought maybe
somebody has already calculated this and
I Googled it and I love that the default
response is there is no historical
record of Beethoven winning an award so
funny
but you want a lot yeah I mean I think
I've seen through that lens I would
imagine that Beethoven Mozart yeah
they're gonna they're gonna be Far and
Away the most yeah
so all that said
um there's a few things I wanted to
correct about the record as I look at
Twitter going what the [__] because I
will acknowledge that the list of the
grammy-nominated video game scores is
wildly different than if you look at
like the dice Awards I was confused that
game uh game awards releases how they
did the timing was confusing to me
there's three factors that people don't
know because they don't know how the
recording Academy works and that's
perfectly okay that's what I'm here to
educate about so first off yes the
release window is not the calendar year
it's basically September to September
which is why fire team was included
um and why for example God of War
Ragnarok was not now I can't imagine
bear won't be nominated next year
uh but it's a weird thing that September
30th is the cutoff for the album release
date
um for for consideration the Grammys
despite the fact that they don't
announce nominees until October and the
awards are not until February so it
doesn't like you can have a game that's
been out for months and like crushing it
and but it's still theoretically six
months away from even submitting to the
Grammys uh so it's a fast so it's like
just one of those odds what ends up
happening would you say they basically
do it very slowly like you and I have
been I don't remember what it was we're
gonna we've done a few video game juries
where it's been the same thing like
we've done a few of them at the same
time and some of them I find really hard
because they're like hey you have two
weeks here's all the nominees play all
of them that can be very very difficult
and I feel like some of them they give
you a month or whatever but the ones
that are like really short periods of
time it's it sucks especially I did a
narrative one so I had to finish like a
whole bunch of like 20 Alec games
um that was Baptist I think it was
really really tough um I feel like
doing that for albums albums aren't as
long but you probably have to listen to
a lot of them and you wouldn't want to
you can't
do it all we can't just sit there and
listen to it maybe like they give people
time to absorb them a little bit
differently because music is such a
different format to a video game story
that you play through like it's just
more time otherwise I can't because four
months is a long time
to vote
well it's not it's it's it yeah it's not
that it's actually more like two weeks
because
uh once the eligibility period is over a
few weeks later they send out the
ballots and they tell you here's
everything that's on the the like long
list ballot of basically everything that
was submitted and a few things are
deemed ineligible or whatever and and
cut off the list but generally speaking
it's whoever submitted here's the long
list and you'll get sent a list of in
the case of video games there was give
or take 70 submissions
um which is pretty good for a new
category that's actually pretty close to
the average across every category except
the like album of the Year song of the
year those always have like well over a
thousand but it's always invariably like
even despite that there being that many
it's just very obviously going to be
like whatever Adele did whatever Taylor
Swift did whatever like you know there's
it's just gonna come down to that
generally speaking but
um but for these more specialized
categories
um it's usually around 70. so one of the
things is that they also don't let you
vote in every category you're only
allowed to vote in 10 categories across
three Fields so like the soundtrack
category is What's called the visual
media field and there's four categories
there there's the soundtrack for game
soundtrack for film what they call
compilation soundtrack which is like
when an album comes out like you know
how black panther released two albums
they go here's the score and then here's
like a bunch of like hip-hop and cool
Fusion music and stuff that's from slash
inspired by the movie that would be a
compilation album oh the SEC the second
one totally different category of the
Grammys it has its own it has its own so
like in Kanto had a album of Jermaine's
score and it had all the songs so the
song one one the compilation album The
Score one
I really need to see it
I thought it was fine I thought the
score was quite nice I I did uh uh like
I was quite happy for Jermaine I thought
I thought she deserved it um and the
fourth visual media one is best original
song which also went to Encanto for you
we don't talk about Bruno yeah
lin-manuel Miranda so
um yeah not surprising but it also was
one of those where it felt like a
thousand years ago because that was last
year's Oscar nomination so that always
happens with the Grammys because of the
weird tilt in the calendar they often
pick up the previous years like when I
when Journey was nominated one of the
things I was nominated against was the
thing that 11 months earlier had won the
Oscar for it was a French film silent
film called the artist and a French
composer named Ludovic Boris he won the
Oscar for that score and he was
nominated in the in the Grammys in that
same category that Journey was back
before they split games apart when did
Assassin's Creed valve Hollow come out
Valhalla I think came out was this was
the DLC so oh I missed that okay yeah a
lot of people in fact this is what
confused people because it's not it's
not just DLC because there's been two
Valhalla dlc's CJ Paris and the dawn of
Ragnarok so hilariously the other
Ragnarok is what won the first video
game Grammy yeah okay I didn't realize
and the composer is a woman named
Stephanie ekonomu amazingly enough those
two DLCs as one thing was her first ever
work in games she's mostly done filming
TV before this wow so I was I was I was
like hell of a start well done
um she's wonderful she's uh and and you
know like it's you know
like just a wonderful person clearly
very talented and has a long track red
it's not like she's some fresh out of
college person or anything like that or
even if she was it wouldn't matter they
don't care what matters is the is you
know is the work and obviously also the
visibility like Assassin's Creed is an
immediately knowable name yeah I was
gonna say there's three things that
govern
why this list is so different from like
dice or the game awards or whatever so
one is the release window yeah
um two is the the Grammys don't go
looking for the best thing that you
submit to them right and a lot of record
labels and things did not know this was
coming and didn't get their [__]
together very quickly so there were a
lot of games now there are some that for
the life of me I couldn't fathom how
they weren't nominated like I voted for
and was very passionate and would have
been all too happy to lose to Horizon
forbidden West for example it was on the
list how it didn't get enough to make
the final nominees was baffling to me I
thought I thought it was just absolute
tremendous score so you're able to vote
even though you were nominated
yeah well I mean yeah you yeah you can
you I've been a recording Academy member
for so everyone is just a member of the
recording Academy I mean it's only one
of you What's it gonna do it's just that
like for the stuff I've been on I was
not allowed to be in any voting category
for any game that I worked on in any
capacity because it's a it's because
it's like a voting body that's different
than it's being a committee
um you know like I've definitely been on
Awards committees like Dyson bafta where
if I worked on a thing you obviously
have to say like hey I scored this thing
that's like in your pool in the case of
baftas they just straight up we're like
then you're not you're like you're not
if you're a viable nominee you're not
going to be on the committee they kicked
me out of narrative because of cyberpunk
so I did a different thing from after
that year yeah yeah same I I the year
that pathless came out
I they put me on the um
like games for change or whatever it's
called like the like the I I ended up on
the the sort of like making the world a
better place bafta Community I can't
remember what the word what it's called
which was awesome
you play Such like different games they
are really really cool and you play them
through a very different lens of like it
doesn't matter if it's even a good game
it or if it's well done or if it's buggy
or what you're looking at like is this a
game that has the potential to if the
right person played this it would
actually really kind of alter their
thinking about the world I love those
they're really cool it was half the time
they're really good same same
uh but so uh the release window being
weird the fact that the labels and all
that have to nominate now the credit to
the game audio Network killed which is
like our kind of group of composers and
audio directors and whatnot they
actually made a deal with the recording
Academy where they could submit on
behalf of non-members
um in order to ensure that a lot of
games got submitted so they probably
half the things that were submitted were
because the game audio Network yield was
just churning through the paperwork to
make sure that nobody went unnoticed but
even still not everybody I mean the fact
that you know when I tweeted congrats
Stephanie and there were people going
there's a game Grammy like there's still
people that just had no idea
yeah and that's okay it'll take time
yeah the third thing that's worth
mentioning is because games while
they've been eligible for a long time
um Journey's the only one that it that
ever slipped through
um uh in the entire 20-year period that
games have been eligible for a Grammy
and so they've been eligible but that
means people just want nominated they
were always they were always voting for
film and TV scores and even TV was
heavily marginalized in favor of film
like rare exceptions Game of Thrones got
nominated stranger things got nominated
um so the most popular shows on the
planet yeah exactly right but but
nothing's but it takes being that
basically to compete with whatever the
biggest films were because invariably
the list is dominated by John Williams
and I mean when Journey was nominated
the other nominees were you know Lord of
the Rings composer Howard Shore John
Williams Hans Zimmer uh Trent resner and
Atticus Ross which is who won and that
the one uh sort of unknown other than me
was Ludovic Boris who had just won the
Oscar though for that film The artist so
not unknown but kind of unknown point
being I know you got to run
um
the the uh the the composer Community
who is largely voting on these is
overwhelmingly dominated by people who
score films and don't know much about
games because up till now it was
perceived like games matter so little to
the recording Academy there was no point
in trying to join now they've created
their own I suspect over the next few
years there's going to be a flood of my
friends and colleagues I certainly hope
I've been advocating for this for 10
years to get my friends in there so we
can actually support like what's going
on in games and have awareness but now
that it has its own category I think
there's going to be a huge drive for
people to join and and I suspect what
will happen is that over time
the game awards dice Awards Etc will
start to look a lot closer to the
Grammys in terms of like
uh you know the games that are really
just casting the longest Shadow making
the biggest impact are likely because
people I get it I understand people were
like there was a tweet that I kept
getting tagged in over and over the
other day where somebody goes this list
of the nominees looks like they just
chose five games at random it is a
really strange list yeah it is and I I
understand
that's a big thing with um
people complain like we've spoken about
this before like snubs like this was
snub why didn't this get nominated uh
for TV and film and also TV and it's
usually just that they didn't nominate
it that that
did whatever production company was
responsible for publishing that show
didn't nominate it it doesn't get
dominate it any other way yeah you have
to submit yeah that's a thing that I
didn't know until like maybe the last
couple of years I was like why isn't
this nominated because they didn't
nominate it like it's on the person who
made it to nominate it which is super
and sometimes I have a friend who won a
bafta for a game score and then did a
really high profile game like the next
year and I remember it didn't get bath
the nominated and I called him and I go
um I'm amazed you didn't make the cut
what an injustice and he goes you want
to know what happened someone at the
publisher called me and they like a few
days after the cutoff date they said hey
did you take care of that by the way and
he goes dude that thought you were going
to take care of it and they literally
just never did the paperwork and so it
didn't make it in time and he and so
it's like sorry no no bafta for you this
year it's like so sometimes it is
literally that they just forget
um yeah the other thing that I would be
remiss not to mention was that when Kim
Petrus got up and and made the claim of
being the first trans Grammy winner with
all respect uh Wendy Carlos the original
Tron composer won three Grammys in 1969
uh post-transition and and it's like
considered one of not only the Great
uh like truly like the god of electronic
music like nothing short of like the
almost like the founder of electronic
music in many respects
um but she was one of the first really
high profile trans artists uh at least
in music
um and like 1968 yeah um and won three
Grammys
um for which zombie Brands now imagine
being Trans in 1968 that would have been
a lot oh yeah there's some interviews
with her where she talks about it that
are that are
um like she did that album initially as
Walter Carlos and then by the time it
was like taking flight was already uh
Wendy Carlos although there's an
interesting period
where she would do live shows still
under the name Walter and put on a wig
and stuff because was unsure how well it
could go in a live show setting and then
later realized well [__] it I am who I
am that's really interesting I mean
again a very different time it's all
that's right again it's still hard now
it must have been even harder back then
and that's a yeah that's a great note
let's
I mean I'm happy for Kim Petras but I
was I was like I was like you know I
take I take I take it sort of personally
because Wendy Carlos is like part of the
composer world it's like nah she's she's
a hero too
millions of composers for the last like
40 years like I I we we gotta draw the
line on that one I'm sorry I stand for
Wendy yeah exactly yeah that's awesome
um uh but yeah what was it like being
there like obviously I do have to run
but what was it like being there in
person was it cool
weird yeah it's fun I mean look it was
funny because
um
uh you know bear is a real close friend
and we we kind of you know sort of met
up on the red carpet and basically just
hung out the entire time until it was
over
um and um one highlight moment that was
really funny was we went and stepped we
kind of snuck out for a while and went
and had lunch and with with our ladies
and Angela later was like oh by the way
who's that YouTube guy that you think is
super impressive he was right behind us
but I didn't want to interrupt you and
it took me a while to realize she was
talking about this guy named Jacob
Collier who is like if you're not
familiar with who he is he he is quite
possibly the Mozart of today like he is
probably the single most talented
musician on planet Earth like I'm not
exaggerating the guy is not human damn
Austin I'm serious he's if you go and
watch some of his [__] on YouTube You
Realize
he's just not made of the normal human
stuff I mean he is he is he's like he's
like if data
were a musician and could and could feel
and like but it's that level of brain
power as in musical power he is he is a
freak of nature and the best sense it
really made me want a tangent about this
guy that I just learned about who's like
very young and is breaking all these
like rock climbing records
like just you know his name I don't
remember I'd have to look it up but I
could get into like all this crazy [__]
he's doing four-year-old people thank
you Everest he's 20. and people are
calling him the Mozart of climbing
because it's like he just kind of came
out of nowhere and is just doing [__]
that like like the guy who as a film or
documentary made about him who did the
free climb of El Capitan do you know
about that
no um the basically like giant rock face
in um Yosemite if you've ever been there
it's like very iconic
um a guy did a free climb of it and
there is a documentary about him doing
that which is like an insane thing to do
it took hours no strings no tools
nothing climbs the whole thing crazy
another guy very recently just came and
did it everyone thought that the first
time it was impossible and that no man
would ever do that again and then this
young dude just comes and does it I'll
look it up for the next episode so I
have more information but it's really
really curious learning about it really
like changed my frame of view that day
because I was like humans really can do
a lot more than we think we're capable
of and what am I doing like I don't want
to rock climb but I was like what am I
doing right now that I didn't think I
was capable of and to be fair boxing
probably is that but I was like that's
very inspiring of like I'm not gonna go
climb a rock face with no tools but
people just [__] doing that stuff and
not question like maybe dumb but I
mostly think it's it's super inspiring
to just be like I'm gonna do it I'm
gonna climb that mountain that's what I
do now like all right do it that is a
girl I went to high school with that
that did Everest
um I I want to do Everest just to
um base camp
that's like a bucket list item so I want
to because especially because I can't
walk very far because I have stupid feet
uh and Ankle problems but I was like I
want to train to be able to just get to
face camp I really want to do that at
some point it it is mind-blowing how big
an investment it's like years of
training
to kind of gear yourself up for that
like it's quite especially with today's
just think about the people 100 years
ago
uh you know people who die like it's a
little more than rope and ax or whatever
it's it's and there's nothing that you
can do to train your brain
for you know how like for low oxygen
high altitude just kind of lost their
minds there's no training that anybody
has found that can prepare you for that
I mean what could you I mean it's just
physiological
disputes you don't actually adjust to it
once you leave you immediately like
adjust but anyway I have to go this is
super interesting yeah same uh yeah
obviously Troy and Mike uh Troy has a
leak
family
exactly uh I have a lot of video right
that's awesome winter he's a video again
we'll see you next time
[Music]